ja ich bin diesmal auf den punkt sowie
millionen deutsche das sehen ich habe
die schnauze voll ich habe die schnauze
voll von einer sozialen
ungerechtigkeit und unserem land und von
einer heuchlerischen doppelmoral der
politik denn wenn man etwas von anderen
fordert opferbereitschaft fordert dann
muss man bei sich selbst anfangen und
das bedeutet vor allem dass man auch im
kanzleramt start nicht abschaltet auch
die klimaanlage runtergedreht und vor
allen dingen einen kanzleramts baustopp
wenn man etwas fordert muss man es
vormachen und die menschen und das spiel
jeden tag in hunderten von e mails sind
verzweifelt haben angst alles zu
verlieren und wir helfen gerne aber wir
müssen dabei aufpassen dass wir uns
nicht selbst verlieren und unser land
dabei zerstören und da kommt hier gerade
passiert ist gefährlich und es ist ein
kochkessel für etwas was denn auf den
straßen weiter geht und ich komme aus
einer ecke wo gewalt normal ist und ich
möchte das nicht in unserem land aber
was hier passiert auf den rücken und den
kosten der bürger muss aufhören